The digital economy is breaking things
because most people running digital
companies aren't aware of the operating
system that's beneath what they're
doing.
You know,
there's a good old fashion,
uh,
venture capital driven operating system.
You know,
it's,
it goes back to central currency and
corporatism and chartered monopolies and
really the way our economy works,
which has worked for a good four or 500
years and promoted everything from the
British east India trading company right
through the Walmart and General
Electric.
But when you take that and juice it up
with digital steroids,
weird things start to happen.
You know,
you end up able to tweak and optimize
your business so carefully that you can
really see is it growing,
is it not growing?
What can we do to promote growth,
growth,
growth.
And if your company's not growing,
you end up in big trouble against all
the other players that are growing.
No,
it's simple a power law dynamics.
It's a winner.
Takes all landscape.
So if you have a company like twitter,
which I would see in my old fashioned
view as a successful company,
it makes $500 million a quarter based on
140 character APP success,
right?
No.
In the current environment,
that's a failure because they don't have
a growth strategy.
They don't know how to turn into a video
company,
a news company as social company than
everything company.
And the reason why the digital economy
is breaking our businesses is because
we're taking the old agenda of growth
and running it on digital platforms and
it ends up amplifying and spinning this
priority out of control.
Most of us look at the industrial age as
this natural outgrowth of the need to do
more and better business.
But as I researched it,
I found out that most of the innovations
we came up with in the industrial age
where really for the opposite,
there was a thriving peer to peer
economy right at the end of the Middle
Ages that nobody likes to talk about.
The soldiers had come back from the
Crusades.
They had all sorts of new inventions and
technologies and mechanisms.
They were new trade routes that they had
opened up and they came back to their
towns and they took something that they
found in the Middle East called the
bizarre and they revived it as something
they called the marketplace.
So now people who had just been peasants
working on the land of the Lords started
coming together and trading the stuff
that they made.
And they had all of these really
interesting instruments from market and
local currency and grain based currency.
And all of these evolved really to
promote the exchange of value when the
velocity of transactions between people
and it started to really do well,
which was the problem.
As the peasants became wealthy,
the aristocracy got scared.
Who are these people?
They're not going to be dependent on us
anymore.
So they came up with two main financial
innovations to prevent the rise of this
peer to peer economy.
The first one was the chartered
monopoly.
Really the parent to the modern
corporation,
all the chartered monopoly was,
was a way to say all of you small
businesses are now illegal.
If you want to be in the shoe business,
you have to work for His Majesty's Royal
Shoe Company.
You want to be in the grain business,
you'll have to work for His Majesty's
Royal Grain Company.
So people who were small business people
now became employees instead of selling
the value they created.
Now they sold their time as servants,
as wage laborers.
The second invention they came up with
was central currency,
not such a terrible thing in itself.
It's great to have a long distance
currency that lots of people can use and
value.
But the problem was they made all of the
local currencies illegal.
So the only way people could trade with
each other,
the candlestick maker could trade with
the chicken farmer,
was by borrowing central currency from
the treasury.
So now you had to borrow money at
interest just in order to transact.
And that set in motion,
really a growth cascade.
If you have a currency that has to be
paid back with interest in order to just
to meet,
to make ends meet,
you need an economy that's growing.
You need more money next year.
Then there was this year.
So that worked well for colonial powers.
As long as we can extend into Africa and
South America and North America,
find slaves,
find new resources we could grow.
But what happens when you reach the end
of the planet's growth as we did really
at the end of World War II?
Well then we started to look for really
virtual surface area,
some new way to grow and that was
technology.
We believed that digital technology in
the worldwide web and computers would
really create a new place,
a new virtual territory for us to
colonize.
And it just turns out what we've been
colonizing for the last 20 years is
human attention and human time.
And now it looks like we're even running
out of that.
Or when the Internet first emerged,
people like me thought,
Hooray.
Now we're going to have a way to restore
all that peer to peer connectivity
between people.
And some of the earliest,
uh,
Internet businesses actually sought to
do that in one way or another.
If you look at the path of Ebay and
paypal and etsy and square,
there aren't a lot.
There are a lot of businesses that are
looking at how can we connect people in
a lateral way.
Problem is as those businesses grew and
everybody got interested in the net,
other folks,
the folks who really who,
who started wired magazine or the global
business network,
a lot of folks who were from the old
Nasdaq Stock Exchange,
which had been really depleted ever
since the uh,
biotech crash of 1987 they saw in the
Internet a new avenue for growth.
So for them it wasn't about how are we
going to connect people in new wonderful
ways and let them,
uh,
create an exchange value between them.
It was really more how can we use
digital platforms to extract value from
people in places.
So if you compare an Ebay,
which is promoting exchange to an
Amazon,
which is promoting extraction,
you can kind of begin to see the
difference.
What happens is you end up with digital
businesses that really are started more
in the flip this house model of
business.
Then I'm going to start a business that
helps people and keeps going for 20
years.
People put money into an internet
business in order to get to acquisition
or IPO.
They want to grow this business a
hundred times and then get out.
It's called an exit strategy.
Then it doesn't matter what happens.
So if you have a ride sharing company,
are you going to pay your drivers enough
so that they can have an ecosystem that
lasts 20 years?
No,
you don't care about that.
You can adopt a scorched earth policy
towards this because you only need those
drivers and that whole ride sharing
sector long enough to establish a
monopoly and then move over into
something else.
When the Internet came around,
we all thought we're all going to get to
work at home in our underwear,
in our own time,
exchanging value with one another,
but instead we've ended up with an
internet that takes more time from us,
an Internet that we feel exhausted and
drained when we're done using it,
and that's because we're not using it.
It's using us.
These.
The Internet is really just the
technological front on a whole series of
business plans that are looking to
extract money from us,
time from us,
attention from us,
and if we have none of those things,
at least data from us and we're not
feeling it creating value for us,
we're not feeling,
it really enhanced our ability to create
an exchange value with other people.
It's harder for most of us to make a
living now rather than easier,
and that's not because automation is
doing things better.
It's because we're really facing very
extractive business plans,
extensions of that very same late
medieval squashing of peer to peer
activity,
although now amplified in every device
in our arsenal.
The reason I'm optimistic is because the
metrics are all on the side doing
business well rather than this scorched
earth,
short term extractive model that most
digital companies use.
If you look at the data,
family businesses do better than
shareholder owned businesses on every
single metric except one.
They grow slower during bubbles.
And actually you kind of want to want to
grow slower during bubbles because if
you grow big during a bubble,
then you're part of what pops.
Now,
the reason why family businesses do
better in the long run than shareholder
owned businesses is because the person
running a share,
uh,
the person running a family business
wants it to be around in another
generation or two or three.
The person running a shareholder owned
business wants to extract enough money
from that business so their grandchild
can be given this wad of cash.
The person with a family business wants
the business to be healthy enough so the
grandchild can then run a successful
thriving business.
And because your family name is on the
business,
you don't want to do really mean things
to your employees or do the places where
you operate because then people are
going to hate your family.
You know,
it's your name,
it's your face.
So a very,
uh,
a very different dynamic gets set up in
one that's ultimately more sustainable
as a business.
You know,
and startup founders of startups and
technology businesses have to come to
understand that taking venture capital
and going for the big acquisition,
going for that one out of 10,000 chance
of getting a home run is dumb compared
to taking a very small amount of money
and hitting the single or the double.
In other words,
making 10 or $20 million is not tragic.
It's still enough.
You can still really,
you'll going to get by on that.
You're going to be able to send your
kids to great colleges.
It's not a failure to have millions of
dollars,
but if you have to aim for the billions,
if you are forced to,
your probability is so low.
You know when I look at these founders
running to sequoia and flat iron and y
combinator cause they want to go big and
get the home run,
it looks to me like those people you see
taking their welfare checks and going to
the Bodega and buying lottery tickets
because they want to get the jackpot.
The 43 million,
they have no chance of doing that and
they would have a chance of taking their
five or $10 and actually investing it
and buy a book,
learn how to do something,
get a job.
They have a much more high probability
of succeeding and it just breaks my
heart when I see a kid have a great app,
a great idea,
and then they turn to a venture
capitalist who gives them a ton of money
in a high valuation and then has them
pivot.
The pivot is not to do something better.
All a pivot means is you're going to
abandon what your original business was
in order to come up with something
that's sellable to the next round of
investors,
the next ground of suckers.
Really,
and do you really want to throw away
your business?
Do you really want to dispose of your
idea in order to turn it into the the
brand name on a Ponzi scheme?
You know,
I hope not because there's still so many
great things we can do with these
technologies.
There's so much money to be made.
There's so much,
there's so much revenue in creating
people to one another and helping people
create an exchange value.
You know,
the mantra I would give any startup and
any big business is make other people
rich.
If you make your users rich,
they will come back.
If you make them poor,
you've killed your marketplace.